yes
brother
Alum Z the type of hatred the police
generally have towards Muslim can you
give some tips what kind of dawa we can
do especially to the police people
brother as a question that the type of
hatred that the police have towards the
Muslim can you give some tips how to Da
with them Point number one the general
strategy of dawa Remains the Same what
you seen my tips but one you should
realize
that the police are also human beings
according to me even if they're
non-muslims they are normally good to
the Muslims but somebody has poisoned
their
mind generally I feel according to me
most of the non-muslims in India whether
it be Hindus or the Christians they AR
enemies of Muslims but they have been
poisoned by certain people especially
the politicians for the V bank so now we
have to De poison
them their minds have been poisoned
otherwise they're good human beings
and you cannot say as a whole all the
police are against Muslims yet there are
many what we have to do that we have to
deal with them with with wisdom and if
you hear my talks talking about
similarity between Islam and Hinduism
you can use the same talk with them but
talk to them with courtesy with love
with affection and try to win them over
rather than instigate them more so these
are the roles of the politicians for the
word bank they want to polarize the
people and the successful in trying to
instigate the people against the Muslim
now we we should do dawa and convey the
message and try to tell them that if you
read your scripture in your scripture it
is mentioned believe in one God in your
scripture it is mentioned that there's a
prophet to come Prophet Muhammad
sallallah Al wasallam make it more
popular to tell them to follow their
scriptures and inshallah we'll be United
so we have to De instigate them and the
same dawa that you do with the others
you can do with the police also and
believe me many time the police called
me to give lectures but they been Bombay
I've been to Hyderabad the National
Academy they have called me I give a
talk only to the top people the top 125
all the DS and the IGS and the
commissioner of Police Inspector General
so they want to know and there I CH the
topic misconception about Islam I kept
my talk very short question open and
they enjoyed the same question which is
bombarded by the common non-muslims they
POS the same question and when I gave
the reply most of them were So Satisfied
and the talk go over the question answer
go over everyone crowded around me they
wanted to ask more questions so how you
convey the m is important what happens
that there's a psychology for example
the two people are neutral both of them
are good now one person instigates and
tells that that person is enemy Mr X is
your enemy he tells to Mr y Mr X is your
enemy fine and he tells to Mr X that why
is your enemy now both when they meet
they look at them as with the enemies
they're neutral so one of them is
instigated any of the two X or Y he
starts looking at him like an
enemy and he behaves like an enemy now
when X or Y one of them get instigated
so X takes y for enemy and he behaves
like enemy with him looks at him sternly
or speaks to him rudely so that person
who's neutral he think I have done
nothing why is he being rudely to me he
reacts when X behaves like an enemy to Y
one of them get instigated with X or Y X
get instigated Y is neutral he say this
is wrong when X get instigated he speak
to rudely so then he said ah correct
that Mr a told me he's the enemy I was
wrong that he's not enemy he actual
enemy see why he's behaving and then
moment why retaliates X gets convinced
ah see now he's speak rudely to me so it
is
actually a plot of these antisocial
elements the aim is to disrupt the Peace
of the society so what happens one of
the two gets instigated
and he starts behaving with the other
like an
enemy the other person gets convinced
okay now he's been enemy and the first
person says see I was right see first he
speaks rudely X speaks to Y rudely y
retaliates x says see now he's speaking
rudely to me I was right and why says a
said X is enemy so then the Clash takes
place there are rights that is
infighting so we as good citizens of any
country should not fall in the Trap of
these politicians
for most of the RADS that you see it's a
political gimmick there may be a small
tension that has taken place for any
reason it may be out of ignorance it may
be out of a fault of someone but the
major people back now you see that
coming in the paper everywhere is trying
to get the vot bank I'll do this I'll do
that so here we find that we who are
more educated people knowledgeable
people we should try and diffuse the
tension and expose the intention
the main intention is if they really
talk about religion are they following
the religion all these politician who
talk about their religion majority of
them they aren't good followers of the
religion they will not be knowing the
religion themselves I'm telling you
whether it be Christian politician
whether it be Hindu politician whether
it be Muslim politicians when you really
try and interact with these politicians
how much do they know of the religion
only superficial do they actually
practically follow the
religion so they are using this as a V
bank for the alterior motives so we
should know how to diffuse it with hikma
and da the same way as you see in my
cassette Mah and one thing is there if
people throw stones at you raise
yourself so high the stone should not
reach you so people are throwing stones
at you it become their duty to raise
yourself higher prove to them that what
you're doing is right you raise yourself
so the stone should not reach you so
that's the best policy of dawa and come
to commment term that Allah says in the
Quran that's the best way hope that
answer the question